Emma welcome to the frontrunners yeah
I'm so happy to have him here he's happy
to be here at the bottom of the stairs
you'll see our world-famous orange chair
that is for you great
hi I'm Dave Karger here at the TCL
Chinese Theatre on Fandango frontrunners
and I'm so happy to be joined by Emma
Stone
one of the costars of Birdman Emma
welcome thank you very much this is a
very different kind of movie for you
Birdman how frightening was it when you
first stepped on the set the first day
well I think it was kind of a very
different movie for everyone it was just
it's own unique you know idea in and of
itself so it was um it's actually pretty
exhilarating ultimately it's been quite
a year for you the huge success of the
spider-man movie this summer and now all
of this great buzz for your performance
and Birdman but obviously this all had
to start somewhere what do you think
about when you think about how you first
begun to realize that you could do this
acting thing for a living when I was
about seven years old my first-grade
teacher put me in the school play
something about my personnel and they
hinted to her that'll be dramatic and so
I fell in love with it and then and then
a few years went by and I was a really
really anxious kid I remembered how I
had felt doing that play when I was
seven it's when I was about 11 I told my
parents that if I didn't act I would die
which is not dramatic at all it was
really true yeah it was the truth and it
wasn't overstated so what did they say
it well they're like the furthest thing
from actors you know he took a little
convincing and then I went and I
auditioned for this like acting class at
this place called Valley Youth Theatre
and in Phoenix and I got a part in a
play off of my audition so I played
adarand Wind in the Willows and that was
my first theatrical role that wasn't in
no Turkey for perky I've seen the
picture of you with the fake on your
chest because otters don't have hair all
over their bodies they only have it on
their chest with their guy and you must
love seeing those pictures nowadays I do
actually it's very funny was there
someone there at this Youth Theatre who
really inspired you that you think back
to yeah the the artistic director of the
of the theater is named Bob Cooper and I
wish every kid got this opportunity but
you know how sometimes shy kids when
they join the debate team
or something that kind of forces you
into the opposite of what you're feeling
it opens up this whole part in you
so starting improv at the theater and
sketch comedy gave all of that all of
those things I was feeling as a kid that
I didn't know how to put into anything
an outlet and it was it was just so like
I can't imagine that I would be doing
anything if it weren't for Bob and also
because I was doing a lot of comedy and
a lot of funny parts Bob also put me in
my first dramatic role in the Little
Mermaid
nice so it was pretty it was pretty
dramatic but it also no no picked up a
whole new you know a whole new avenue in
my mind did it calm you down or did you
remain that entirely yeah
I mean not entirely anyone who has known
me knows I'm not probably calm but it it
was like the most productive fantastic
kind of you know channel for for me and
I met people that I got along with and
that's hard at like 11 12 13 to find
people that you really they really click
with so I was totally one of those Glee
kids
okay so at this point in the show I want
to take a look at my favorite scene of
yours from Birdman we're gonna watch it
together with these remotes in our hand
okay and we can pause it and talk about
key moments in the scene you're playing
Michael Keaton's characters daughter now
Michael Keaton's character is a former
action hero who's trying to make
something of a comeback by starring in
and directing a Broadway play yeah so
this is a particularly heated
conversation that you're having let's
take a look at Birdman there's my chance
to finally do some work that she means
something I need something to help you
had a career dad before the third comic
book movie before people started to
forget who was inside that bird costume
it's actually one of my favorite things
about this movie is that you kind of
trip over the line a little bit yeah and
one of the things I like about this
movie is that those moments were kept in
yeah is that because the takes were so
long that you just had to keep going
even if it wasn't perfect you had to
keep going I mean unless you forgot what
you were doing you kept going until you
heard yes or no yelled from the other
room we rehearsed so much and because it
was so kind of finely tuned and
choreographed that anything that felt
you know free and and genuine came out
of just
you know any raw emotion he wanted to
keep in well this movie is certainly
filled with raw emotions as we're about
to see you're doing a play based on a
book that was written 60 years ago for a
thousand rich old white people whose
only real concern is gonna be where they
go to have their cake and coffee when
it's over nobody gives a [ __ ] with you
and let's face it dad you are not doing
this for the sake of art you are doing
this because you want to feel relevant
again well guess what there is an entire
world out there where people fight to be
relevant every single day
and you act like it doesn't exist now I
have two questions here first of all how
close is the camera to your face that
close right and what is Michael giving
you on the part where we can't see him
he's big he's right there is riggan I
mean he's so overwhelmed by everything
that I think kind of alternating between
just not being able to tolerate it and
and paying attention to what she's
saying to him but he was fully present
for that whole thing he didn't like turn
away and hide well you're not done yet
things are happening in a place that you
ignore a place that by the way has
already forgotten about you I mean who
the [ __ ] are you
you hate bloggers you mock Twitter you
don't even have a Facebook page you're
the one who doesn't exist now irony
alert yeah
last I checked Michael Keaton in real
life has Twitter yeah and yet you don't
write so there yeah who doesn't exist I
don't exist today let's keep going
you're doing this because you're scared
to death like the rest of us then you
don't matter and you know what you're
right you don't it's not important okay
you're not important get used to it okay
so here's the moment for me right now I
think you're feeling smug like you've
just let him have it you've told him
right in my mind this is something that
she rehearsed over and over and Rehab
this is something she wrote down and she
has always wanted to say or she wrote in
her journal and she's finally getting a
chance to just like throw it at him it's
an amazing reaction
so now what do you think she's thinking
right now I need to rectify this I need
to comfort him but I mean I would
imagine that that's just a flood because
the the next thing she wants to do is
get high I mean she's been high here but
then there's she needs to go to the roof
just to get some adrenaline there's a
kind of need to be not in her body that
she has so I think it's that paying of
you know something that you always
thought would feel so great actually
being one of the things you regret most
and then and then trying to escape
yourself in some way here's the end
so when that's done what are you and
Michael do do you give each other a hug
do you try to spend some time together
to kind of cleanse yourself of that oh
yeah we definitely hugged once it was
all said and done but it's it was it was
a very very fast shoot and everyone kind
of needed to be as energetic and and
ready to move forward as possible
and what's it like now when you run into
him at a film festival or a premiere or
a press day now that you've gone through
this experience it's it's just so
exciting to see him at all of this stuff
because he's been a favorite actor of so
many people for so long and yet this is
the first time he's really in this like
in something like this and not that
there is anything like this or ever
Wolfie again I don't think so either but
so we're all we're all pretty lucky well
thank you so much for being here and
taking the time today to talk about this
I really appreciate it for having me
Birdman is in theaters now so please
check it out you won't regret it and
thanks so much for watching
Fandango frontrunners so Emma - thank
you for being here today
we have made you your own personalized
Emma Stone in Birdman Fandango gift card
thank you so much enjoy okay so now I
take you over here we do a little photo
you ready one two three
I love it thank you so much I have some
pleasure